my mom putting me first
obviously told me not to come to
california because she didn't want to
get me sick with the virus
for the next week i woke up and texted
my family
and we had a coronavirus update chad
however one day my mom didn't respond to
my text messages
my mother my brother told me that my mom
was weak and she was
having trouble and she was going to the
emergency room
for the next two days i waited on my
phone
for updates every single minute
i'm happy to say my mom is still alive
today
by the grace of god but for 213 000
americans
they weren't that fortunate this virus
didn't have to take away someone's mom
dad brother sister wife or
grandma it's completely the fault of the
trump administration
and their many failures that brought us
to this position we're at now
that is why i'm in this fight for joe
he has a plan and we need to get jill
elected
as our next president with 25 days into
the election
one way you can do to get joe elected is
by reaching out to your existing network
your family your friends your neighbors
and anyone else you know and having a
conversation
about why you are supporting joe biden
and why they should too and how do you
do this
you ask get your phone out right now
and go to the app store and download
vote joe app
that's the vote joe app from there
you can import your contacts and begin
having real conversations with them
about this election and why they need to
vote for joe
and kamala harris on november 3rd and
why
they are the best candidates to lead our
country moving forward
i also want you to do me a favor i want
you to post all your content today
all your pictures all your videos on
social media
with the hashtag joe and envy because
today
las vegas joe is in nevada
this election is in our hands we will
decide the future of the next four years
don't let anybody tell you different
your vote matters
and you need to vote and your family
needs to vote and your neighbor needs to
vote
thank you so much for having me and i
wanted to introduce you to
our next artist dj d miles for
entertainment tonight thank you so much
las vegas
well
wake up
uh
yes
is
let's check
welcome to our drive-in voter
mobilization event with vice president
joe biden
if you would like to help get out the
vote and elect joe biden and kamala
harris
please take united to 30330 right now
that's
30330 and welcome and thank you for
joining us
who should take me home tonight
hello
oh
oh
right you to the edge
stories of love
you gotta play
so
let's see what i can see
sometimes life just got the best
take some chances
mmm
love for me
love about y'all it's all about family
it's about family
it's about family and faith and loyalty
and that's what
that's what i think when every time i
think of here and so i want to thank you
now i tell you what uh edgar planned on
bringing in
20 horses in here but he didn't couldn't
get him in today
tell you what i've had people campaign
for me i've never had them go through
the neighborhoods with me on horses but
my dad who was a real equestrian would
have really been flattered to know
you're doing this
folks you look uh you know it's great to
be back at the center and uh
they're so i have to tell you all
there's so much at stake
and uh you know here we are we've gone
through so much since i was here last
because of the incompetence of this
administration 200 000
ten thousand people dead we're in a
situation where
that's forty thousand latinos nationwide
forty thousand thirty million people
lost their jobs
three million latinos lost their jobs
one in three
latino businesses have uh have closed
and the deep racial injustices that
trump continues to fan the flames of
it's just wrong you know we have to end
this cycle
where in good times you're being left
behind
in bad times you're the first in trouble
and as we come out always the last to
come out
you know uh this is uh this crisis
we have i think though an enormous
opportunity
to build back better i'm going to be
very short so i'm not going to keep you
standing very long don't worry
but i really feel strongly about this i
think we're in a circumstance
where you know you all understand it but
the american public is beginning to
understand it
you are the core of the american story
you have a potential you're already an
economic powerhouse but the potential
to lead the country in the 21st century
in the direction
that we need to go you have close to 20
percent of the population in the united
states
24 to every 100 kids in grade school
through high school or latino and it's
it's ridiculous that we continue to
policies that this administration has
moved forward on and not embrace that
and see it as our future
i'm not trying to be solicitous with you
i'm not trying to be nice you are
the future of the country i mean you
really are
if in fact if in fact we're in a
situation where
the latino community in the united
states of america and their
the gdp the what the wealth that they
generate nationwide
if it just took just the latino
population you'd be the eighth largest
economy in the world
in the united states why can't we see
that the future is just absolutely
breathtaking
if we just use our heads and begin to
operate in a way that i think the
american people are ready to do
the blinders have been taken off the
american people they get it
they understand they understand that all
those folks in the front lines look at
how many dreamers are out there risking
their lives
for i mean you know it but the american
people don't know what i keep telling
them all over the country
the dreamers there's thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
them
risking their lives making sure that
people are staying alive they can stay
home
and so folks look we're going to be in a
situation where
we can't make this we can't do it
without you all
we cannot win without the community
and i'm going to say something somewhat
self-serving about you all
the fact is you can determine
the outcome of this election not just
not just for president but for the
senate for the congress
and that's the biggest mark the single
most consequential thing anyone can do
is vote
and when you vote and they add it up and
they see who delivered the vote
that's the thing that guarantees that
guarantees significant input on what
happens next
so folks early voting starts the clock
is ticking
when he starts here in just eight days
on the 17th
and uh i'd encourage you to tell all
your friends
go to iwillvote.com now
make sure they're registered their
addresses are up to date on the ballot
and they have a plan to vote the early
voting right here
right at this spot so come back next
weekend
bring your family and bring five friends
i really mean it
bring other people with you because that
he's trying to scare us he's trying to
continue convince everybody there's ways
they can play with the vote
and and undermine the vote they can't
if we show up we win and look what's
happening in early voting all across
america
long lines long lines we can't just win
we have to win
overwhelmingly so you can't be in a
position where you can
put the phony challenges that he's
talking about so folks
the american people they're going to
want to decide our future
not this president attorney general who
is less than straightforward
you're the ones so let's get out and
vote i know the sun is how do i want to
keep you standing
and i want to thank the elected
officials this week call and i tell them
this we call a bustman's holiday that
means you know when a busman has a
holiday he
has a day off the guy driving he doesn't
get back on the bus
well these folks are all on the bus
they're elected officials and they're
here to like
hear another elected official i can't
thank you enough for your support
i give you my word i will do everything
in my power
to deliver on all that i've said i mean
it from my heart
you are family family and faith it was
driven
this community that's going to drive
this country and so folks
let's go get them every time i'd walk
out of my grandpop
my my grandpa wasn't
my grandpop was not
hispanic he was an irishman and every
time i'd walk out of his door
up in scranton pennsylvania he'd say
joey
keep the faith you know my grandma when
she's live with yell
no joey spread it let's go spread the
faith okay
thank you thank you thank you
and by the way i promise you if i win
you're getting an invitation to
washington
okay not a joke
not a joke thank you you're the best
right
mommy
battleground state where we are where we
represent not only the growing diversity
of the country
but the growing support towards radical
progressive movements
early voting starts on october 17th and
that is the perfect opportunity to sign
up to volunteer and unite your community
to build back better
raise your hand and wave to talk to any
of the wonderful organizers going around
and they can tell you more about our
community events thank you
ah
wow
hey
thank you
that's okay
all right i'll give them a call now
yeah i know but you know what they're
all jobs
it looks
getting in there nice than these put
their tongue in not these groups but
squats who aren't good at what they do
they're just cheaper yeah
um
oh
all right
okay
good afternoon and welcome to our voter
mobilization event with president joe
biden
if you would like to get out and vote
and elect joe biden and commodities
please text
united to three zero three three zero
right now
that is three zero three three once
again welcome to our driving
voter mobilization event thank you
hey you got pretty
stand there at the podium
if you want to take it off to get the
lighting thing i'm fine with it just
have it hanging on an ear
have it visibly there so i don't have uh
okay
all right
thank you
daddy
um
ready
all right
you with me
one
i told my wife
hey you might want to tell your guys
that's a better shot it's not for me
yeah actually this is for anthony he's
going to hold a boom
coming in
me
is
oh
oh yeah
okay
it's
god
oh
now
foreign
walmart
uh
me
thank you
oh
oh
yes
hi everybody my name is patrick i'm an
organizer here with the
democratic party
that's what i'd like to hear uh so like
a lot of people here in las vegas
are actually not really from this area
and they're at risk
but that's actually why i really like to
work here it gives you an opportunity to
work with people from all walks of life
from all over this country
whether they're from california or new
york or pretty much
from california
i need to experience like all these
different
ideas and values that you don't normally
get to see
that's actually you know whatever the
value of other working here in vegas too
is
it's almost like a melting pot
that's what inspires me every single day
is seeing people either come here
whether you were born here whether you
were here for
20 years or three months maybe
people are working together to make this
place better
for ice i'm on that camera for everybody
so you see down here in vegas right now
democratic parties
the way from germany to the united
states
i just
doesn't seem to care about all the
different communities here
but all the different communities that
we represent and we work for them we
fight for
so that's what i'm doing the next 25
days i'll be making phone calls i'm
going to be sending texts
enjoy
thank you guys for being here appreciate
it
and i look forward to being in this
fight with all of you for the next 25
days
and every day after that for the next
four years
i'm going to lift this camera this way
ready
yeah you need to have clarence replaced
how do you want to handle that
i have the whole team coming back for
strike that was over at the other side
hi what do you think
okay
is
is
i love you
okay
hey
oh
okay
is
is
hello
what's your favorite
so
so
oh
that's
so
foreign
is
um
hello
thank you
oh
oh
like this
good
okay
okay
but from the
there's stratosphere building and
there's
nothing there i mean it buildings like
that
so
yo if you had regular october weather
this wouldn't be
serious it's hot as [ __ ] dude
thank you
what's right
[ __ ]
my
yes
foreign
seasons
i
is
uh
foreign
please
saturday gonna script
so
is
first
i'm
oh
me
foreign
oh
hey
for me
foreign
foreign
no
foreign
thank you
oh
uh
okay
happy
oh
foreign
okay
hey
foreign
i
so
they're coming to any time
foreign
oh
oh
okay
okay
um
okay
oh
is
okay
at this point
three minutes alex
oh
you want to stop
[ __ ]
it's been a very long
my name is madison taylor i'm a field
organizer with nevada democrats
you know thank you in all honesty i
am completely terrified of public
speaking i have been
my entire life i would even go as far in
high school
as to fake sick so that i could get out
of speeches
and i did the same in college as well i
am here today because i believe in this
cause so strongly that i chose today to
overcome that fear
thank you
the democratic party helped me see how
strong of a woman i am
and how much power that i have just at
the tips of my fingers
i believe in them and they believe in me
too
i am here to speak for all the people
that are afraid to speak up
the day has come i am here to give you
your platform
to use your voice let's protect women's
reproductive rights
environmental rights food assistance
programs
yes yes let's win this election
use your voice grab your friends and
family and come volunteer with the
nevada democrats
election day is only 25 days away
and we need as much help as we can get
you can download the vote joe app and it
will connect you with your friends and
family
and it will even send out texts for you
so you don't even have to worry about
typing it
and thank you so much for giving me this
platform and i hope to see you use yours
as well
now thank you
now i am proud to introduce our next
speaker someone nevada
is very lucky to have leading our state
governor steve sislak
good afternoon nevada
you've got an incredible lineup of
speakers coming here today
and some of the hardest working folks
that i know are here to support
the next president of the united states
joe biden
we are grateful to have our next pres
our next president
here with us today with just 25 days to
go
until election day and only eight days
until early voting begins we need to
stay
focused and double down right now
and that includes electing joe biden
kamala harris dina titus susie lee
stephen horsford
and democrats up and down the ticket
now i'm gonna do something here i'm not
hearing enough horns and i want you to
welcome
our next president loudly so i brought a
little heroine here
so join us please in welcoming president
biden when he comes out here because he
will be our president
nevada families cannot afford to
continue down the path we are on
right now we are a battleborn state
we know how to fight we've done
incredible work together
to fight this pandemic without any
leadership coming out of washington
i can tell you i had the opportunity to
speak to my good friend
and colleague gretchen whitmer in
michigan
and what she's going through and the
difference in character
joe biden calls her up and asks her how
she's doing
donald trump gets on national tv and
won't disavow
white supremacists that's the difference
we need real leadership we can't do it
alone
joe and kamala can't do it alone they
need all of us
leaders who understand the tragedy two
hundred and twelve thousand american
lives are lost
two hundred and twelve thousand
and we've got a president gets on tv and
says it's going away it'll be gone by
easter it'll be
we've got a cure we don't and we've had
no leadership coming out of washington
to protect
our citizens in nevada that's why
we're all here today to remind ourselves
of everything that's at stake
and to take a step towards the future
your vote your one vote can make a
difference whether we continue down this
path of chaos
and disorganization or we restore
compassion and leadership to the white
house
with biden harris
can't hear you
your voice can be the difference when it
comes to our state recovery
when it comes to lives being saved and
nevadans getting back to work
casting a ballot will make the
difference between four more years
of a president who wants to terminate
health care who denigrates veterans
deny science and won't denounce white
supremacy
that's what we've got right now and we
can't have that anymore
we need a president who will expand
access to affordable care
protect our environment who understands
the sacrifice our service men and women
make
and their families make it gets our
country back on track
we know we'll make the difference
because nevada is a battleground state
and the road to the white house runs
right through nevada
so it's on us not just do we need to
vote we've got to make a plan to vote
make our voices heard and ensure we turn
out our family
our friends our neighbors and our
co-workers
there are so many ways to vote this
election
we made sure that in the last special
session there were many ways to vote
and protect your vote without giving up
your health and safety
unlike the president we've got now that
spreads lies about
what our voting process works here in
nevada
in an attempt to suppress the turnout
nevada democrats have worked hard to
expand access to the ballot box
many nevadans are beginning to vote
because we have the opportunity to vote
by mail
you can fill out your ballot sign it and
mail it back immediately
or you can take it to a dropbox location
you can vote in person beginning october
17th
that's next saturday
through october 30th or you can vote in
person
on november 3rd but whatever way you
choose
make a plan and vote
then after you voted make sure everyone
you know
has made a plan and they get out and
vote
no matter which way you vote do it early
joe and kamala can't afford to do they
can't do this alone
they need every one of you every one of
us
up and down the ticket voting for
democrats
to support our candidates
so when we have the vice president walk
out here
i want you to give them the loudest warm
nevada welcome you ever can
and the last thing we got to do let's go
out and win this thing
thank you
you're clear on the tv
please welcome congresswoman dina titus
let's make some noise
thank you thank you well hello las vegas
are you ready let me hear it let me hear
it
you know we've got 25 days
25 days to elect two people
to do one big job we got
25 days to elect joe biden
and kamala harris to restore the soul of
this country
are you up for it
are you in with me to do it
are we going to make it happen yes we
are yes we are i want to thank governor
sisselvac for his leadership in helping
nevada get through this virus in
economic hard times
he's been a great leader and has stood
strong for us
let's thank him again
yes
now some of you may remember that i've
been riding with biden for a long time
back from the very beginning back before
any votes were
cast and when we had a whole stage full
of really great democratic candidates
and the reason i chose to endorse joe
biden
is because i know joe biden i knew he
had the depth
of knowledge the breadth of experience
and the strength of conviction to make a
good president
on day one i knew from his
own life that he had the compassion in
his heart
and the steel in his spine to get the
job done
i knew that he knew that being
progressive like me
means making progress and getting things
done
i knew joe biden but more importantly i
knew that joe biden
knows us joe biden knows nevada
you know if you've ever sent a family
member
off to war joe knows your sacrifice
if you've ever lost a loved one to a
dreaded disease
joe biden knows how much that hurts
if you've ever been bullied because you
had a disability
joe biden's been there he knows what
that's like
if your father or family member ever
lost a job
they didn't know how they were going to
feed the children
joe biden was there when his father went
through that
and if you've ever been told hey it's
not your turn
or you can't do it or oh don't make me
laugh
joe biden knows what it means to
persevere
show what you're made of and get it done
he knows how to do that that's why he'll
be a good president
you know when joe biden looked me in the
eyes and said nevada
will never be a nuclear dump site you
will not have yucca mountain
i knew we could trust him
and when he speaks about the need for
criminal justice reform
and ending systemic racism we can trust
him
he's as good as his word
and we and he says climate change and
gun violence
are issues we need to address right on
and we need to do it now we can trust
that's what he means
and he'll do what he says
and when he says that diversity and
immigrants are what makes this country
strong we can
all believe that that will be what he
pushes for
and when it comes to who will listen to
the scientists
and help us to big build bill big bill
big back better
we know that joe biden means it and we
can trust him to do that
on the other hand we also know that we
can't afford four more years of donald
trump
this country can't stand four more years
of his recklessness
his lies his corruption is not
caring about the people of this country
people in nevada are still hurting and
he says oh we'll wait till after the
election and then i'll give you a good
deal
well we can't afford to wait we children
are hungry
people need to pay the rent businesses
need to reopen
we can't wait so you gotta go donald
trump you gotta go
so whether you choose to vote in person
go early mail it in show up on election
day
lots of options make a plan to do it
take your family with you take your
neighbors take your sunday school
teacher take your hairdresser take the
grocery clerk
get everybody to turn out and vote in
this election it's
too important to sit on the sidelines
we got 25 days are you in
are you going to do it are we going to
elect joe biden the next president of
the united states
yes we are thank you very much
thank you
foreign
please welcome congressman steve
horsford
hello nevada
how are we feeling out there today
well sonja and i are incredibly excited
to be here with all of you
to welcome vice president joe biden back
to the silver state
i know that we're all ready to listen to
his vision
and future for how he's going to move us
forward and what he's going to lay out
but i also want to talk a little bit
about the path
our country has been on under the
current president
our nation has seen many unprecedented
situations this year
from this incredible terrible pandemic
that has damaged the economic and
physical health of our nation
through natural disasters and social
turbulence
our country has truly been in dire
straits this pandemic
has devastated nevada and our economy
plunging us collectively into the worst
economic downturn
of our generation and the national
leadership
has been misguided and full of empty
promises
this virus has claimed over 210
000 american lives and continues to put
many more out of work nevadans
need relief and we needed it quite
frankly eight weeks ago
when unemployment benefits ran out
negotiations need to resume
so that hard working families can put
food on the table
purchase life-saving medicine and afford
child care
this relief is long overdue
but most importantly it's highlighted
the areas the current
president has let us down
these difficult times require steady
leadership
they require a leader who has been there
before
someone who is willing to have tough
conversations
and be strong when responding to the
tough questions
i'm proud to have been an early
supporter of the vice president
because we need a change and he will
help facilitate that change
we need leaders who understand that this
virus won't simply go away
leaders who have the experience of
fighting for those who can't afford
to pay their rent put food on the table
or purchase
life-saving medications because they've
lost their jobs
the very location that we're at the
southeast career technical academy
reminds me of my own background where i
spent more than a decade
leading nevada's largest job training
academy in the state
the culinary training academy
we must provide nevadans with the
opportunity to earn a good paying job
with this kind of experience i can
recognize the type of leader we need
joe biden is that leader
he understands that this crisis needs a
steady hand
commitment and empathy we
know joe but more importantly joe
knows us he knows our hopes
our dreams and our ambitions he knows
that work needs to be done
to undo the lasting effects the trump
administration has left on this country
joe biden and senator kamala harris will
put this nation
back on the right track the values of
this ticket go beyond politics
it's about the shared american
experience
this ticket is now representative of who
america is yes
this is an economic crisis and joe biden
and senator kamala harris
know that we really are in a battle for
the soul
of our nation this election will call
upon all of us
to take action we must be willing to
show up to vote to responsibly
talk to our neighbors and friends and
make
our voices heard so i'm calling on you
every
nevada democrat to make sure that our
country moves forward
and that we provide opportunities and
jobs for all nevadans
so make a plan make a plan to
vote absentee vote early or vote by
election day
and oh while you're at it make sure
you've completed the census
are you ready to get out there and elect
joe biden
our next president of the united states
let's get out there let's do what it
takes and when
thank you and god bless you
please welcome congresswoman susie lee
hello nevada hello
henderson i want to welcome
the blue machine all of you
are responsible for turning nevada blue
in 2018. thank you
welcome to the heart of congressional
district 3.
i am a proud representative of all of
you in congress
you know we're here today we got 25 days
left to kick off the final
push we are almost there to get
joe biden elected as the next
president of the united states
and i must say we've been down quite a
journey here
in nevada uh you know we are the poster
child
for how this administration has
failed this country in its response
to this pandemic people are out of work
businesses are on the verge of collapse
our friends our families
our neighbors our parents have suffered
and are suffering and we ask where
is the leadership well i'll tell you
where it starts
it starts right here in nevada with our
incredible governor steve sisilak
and it started in congress with the
democrats who turned out the family's
first act
and the cares act to get aid into our
communities
as soon as possible to save businesses
but we got a little ways to go it's been
five months since we passed the heroes
act but republicans didn't want to do
anything
and then we have a president in a tweet
who says i'm ready to walk away that's
walking away
from all of you and i know
who would not play games with people's
lives
and that is the next president of the
united states
joe biden
joe knows he knows pain he knows
adversity but he knows how to fight
and he knows how to stand up for working
families in america
it's what he has done and what he will
continue to do
and i will tell you what is at stake in
this election as he always says it's the
soul of our country
do we want four more years of cover-ups
and lies
or do we want four years of truth
do we want four years of chaos
or four years of calm do we want
four more years of fear or
four more years of hope
four years of division or four years of
unity
i know where you all stand
and for biden to win nevada he
must win congressional district three
and they are coming after him hard here
you know pence was just here yesterday
trump was here a couple weeks ago they
are looking at
congressional district 3 as their path
to victory in nevada and that's why i
need all of you
to do everything you can in the next 25
days
and guess what they want someone
uh someone to ride some coattails and
his name is
big dan rhodeimer and we're gonna stop
big dan in his tracks because he's as
dangerous as the man in the white house
he wants to basically take a chair
to the back of washington that's not how
you start off a relationship when the
country is in the middle of a crisis
what you do is you pull up a chair and
you sit down
and you have the tough conversations and
you work things out
and that's exactly what i've done and
that's exactly the type of leadership
that joe biden
will bring to the white house
you know
you know i'm i'm one of eight children i
grew up in canton ohio
and my mom always said to me you know
you got to be so good that no one can
take it away from you
and that is how we have to treat this
election
every single vote from every single
corner
we have got to work and get it out so we
can win this
by a landslide
you know in the past four years i think
a lot of us have like news fatigue where
you wake up in the morning and you're
like god
i don't really want to know what's in
the news
because it's sort of like drinking a cup
of sour milk
it tastes real bad and it's got a real
bad aftertaste but i'll tell you what
i'm looking forward to
i'm looking forward to january 24th
pouring myself a nice cup of warm
joe let's hear it for joe biden get out
there
we are in this to win this we need every
one of you
nevada knows how to get it done joe
biden kamala here's let's do it
all right
please give it up for your national your
nevada congressional leaders
please welcome senator jackie rosen
hello everyone good afternoon nevada
good afternoon henderson
are you ready to vote
are you ready to win
and are you ready to send joe biden and
kamala harris to the white house
let's do it because i gotta tell you
i am so excited to be here today and
have vice president biden with
us too and we're going to call him
president biden soon enough
and i know that everyone here is more
than ready to get him elected
you know why because joe biden knows us
he knows our country he knows nevada
he's been here and he sat with us at our
kitchen tables
he understands the issues that are
important to us
the challenges we face and he knows them
better than anyone else
and let me tell you i've spoken to
countless
nevadans and i can say with certainty
that no issue matters more
to the people of our state than
protecting the health
of their loved ones
you know the affordable care act
the bill that obama and biden
administration championed
they've not only ensured that our
families have peace of mind and quality
coverage here in nevada
but it's literally saved thousands of
lives
in our state nearly 1.2 million people
live with a pre-existing condition if
donald trump gets four more years in
office we're going to see an immediate
end to the aca
and the health care for millions
millions of americans
will be lost and now
we're in the middle of a deadly pandemic
pandemic one that has claimed the lives
of over 210
000 souls two hundred and ten thousand
families
are about to have an empty seat at their
thanksgiving table
not just this year but every year
for the rest of their lives two hundred
and ten 000 families
whose stories will be forever changed
and we know that health care and
pre-existing conditions
are just more important than ever and
joe biden has a plan to strengthen our
health care system
to expand our coverage and to reduce our
cost
donald trump's plan is to leave us high
and dry leave our nevada families
hanging out to dry
nevada needs a president who deals with
this pandemic head-on
not someone who buries their head in the
sand nevada needs a president who will
provide an economic
lifeline not someone who steps away from
the negotiation
table and leaves nevadans unable
to pay their bills at the end of the
month
nevada needs a president who sees the
dignity in
every american life
nevada needs a president like jill biden
in the white house
a president with a plan a president who
protect our health care a president who
will stand up for workers in small
business
a president who will not only help build
nevada back
but we'll build it back better than ever
joe biden's plan his plan is going to
allow us to beat this pandemic
to reopen safely and get real relief to
working families
but joe biden won't stop there building
back
better means creating millions of good
paying jobs
building back better means strengthening
our health care system
building back better means fighting for
gender equality and racial equality
it means supporting child care family
care
education building back better
means investing in all of nevada's
communities
building back better building back
better means working together to build a
better country
one with a level playing field one where
every american
has a fair shot at the american dream
one
where we make sure to lift up those
among us
who need it the most
and you know thank you
the stakes in this election it just
couldn't be higher
we can protect our health care we can
see that economic relief
is delivered we can see this end to an
era of division is era of hate
this era of fear so i'm
telling you i know you all know this
from our heart
it's never ever been more important that
we vote this november
and in nevada right here in nevada we
can
and we must early vote
erling early vote starts next saturday
saturday october 17th it runs to friday
october 30th
if you want to avoid lines on election
day you should find the early vote
location nearest you and make a plan to
vote now and a plan to vote
safely you need to
vote like your life depends on it
because it
just might it also might depend
for the ones that you love so make a
plan you can vote by mail
you can vote early you can vote the day
of
make a plan make sure everyone you know
has a plan to vote and
make sure they can get there and vote
like their life depends on it because
you know what in nevada
we understand what it means to have a
great
legislature a great governor
and you delivered for catherine cortez
masto
in 2016 sending the first latina to the
united states senate
nevada i thank you because you
delivered for me in 2018 and you made
nevada one of the seventh state in the
country to have two
women senators
and now we have an opportunity to send
joe biden and kamala harris to the white
house
we have an opportunity to repeat all
this magic
in a big way so on behalf of senator
catherine cortez masto
and myself we welcome joe to nevada
we look forward to him being our
president and coming back to nevada
time and time again and i know
we stand ready to greet him each time
and we stand ready today to get make a
plan to vote
and deliver for joe this november
sending him to the white house
and if you needed any more reason i'm
just going to tell you this
joe biden and kamala harris
they have the heart to be there joe
biden
believes in the future of our nation he
is ready to tackle the crisis we
face head on so let's show nevada what
we know let's show the rest of the
country what we know about nevada
that we're nevada strong that we're
nevada proud and that we
will vote for competence for integrity
and for a better tomorrow and for joe
biden
thank you
you
this
you
we're gonna go back up
peace
um
nope
you
please welcome pastor kelsey west for an
invocation
good afternoon i bring you greetings
from nehemiah ministries christian
church
i ask that you would please join me for
a moment of prayer
to only wise god our savior as we gather
in and for this moment that will
contribute to one of the most greatest
chapters in our history
we thank you for not only the gift of
life but for the gift of this new day
we thank you for the blessing of this
community of colleagues
allies friends and extended family we
thank you for the generations of men
and women whose brave and strong
shoulders we continue
to stand on as we near the eye and dawn
of the november elections
we thank you for raising up judges in
the form of political servants like vice
president joe biden
and senator kamala harris who have
presented themselves
for public service while opening their
lives to public scrutiny
we thank you for the day's work the
dollars given the miles walked
and the hours of sleep that have been
sacrificed and invested by
these candidates as well as their
families and friends staff
and volunteers as we work to be swift to
hear and slow to speak on this day
let our minds extend beyond the zip
codes that we call our community
and reflect upon those who reside in
states of vulnerability
that need our support and advocacy
children and families
people without enough to eat those
facing eviction in cities with vacant
buildings
people suffering from side effects that
have produced life
altering afflictions within their mind
body and spirit
as well as those who who are
unpublicized and undocumented victims of
racism and sexism
and all the other isms that make us a
nation and or our house divided against
itself
please lord bless those who have never
been called essential
but yet served with little to no pay on
the essential front lines that we call
academic classrooms and let us not
forget those who have seen and felt
coveted up close master we trust that
this pandemic
wind and economic storm will soon cease
but should it not more sooner than later
later let our
let not our hearts lose hope in the fact
that you are still our light and our
salvation
please lord bless those who stand in
need of justice today
let not only freedom ring but let
verdicts prove that we are not only
created equal
but in your image so may it be according
to isaiah 43 and 19
for we expect you with exceeding great
joy to do a new thing in this country
that will spring up and allow us to
behold a way in the wilderness a new way
in the wilderness and strains in the
wasteland that we have never witnessed
before
in the mighty matchless and majestic
name of jesus to christ we pray
amen
so
please welcome angelica vallarta for the
singing of the national anthem
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early light
what so proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the perilous fight
all the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming
and the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in
air gave proof
through the night that our flag was
still there oh
say does that star-spangled
banner yet wave
or the land of the frame
and the hope of the
braves
okay
whatever is is
shhh
um
they said something that really changed
my outlook
but it got better
very good i'm so very proud and
wonderfulness
or he's walking on the stage
when it comes down to it we all know
that we're connected by much
moral
more
generous confident an optimistic nation
full of hope and
for the president resolved down fear
but i believe americans are stronger
than that
i believe will be guided by the words of
pope john paul ii
what we've always done in fact it's what
we have done best and continue to do
best this is the united states
my name is
he's going to the podium and he has on
the right on the floor next to the
podium or
a spare handheld just in case then
there's nobody else
is
what's up north carolina chris paul here
more than ever
this election is so very important in
north carolina
the homestay and myself it was great for
me to spend as much time
and every person how important it is
today
i won't have time to run up there
yes
oh
is
kindness
in school gymnasiums
foreign
you're walking out
i just told molly
as a reminder today's event has been set
up to adhere to social distancing
guidelines
as outlined by health experts in the
state of nevada thank you for being here
correctly
foreign
i'll let them know i know
they fixed it six times uh
is
is
that's so
please welcome alejandro du hart
hello las vegas my name is alejandro
duhart
and it is a privilege to be here
today when i first came to this country
when i was in the eighth grade i never
thought
i'd be standing in front of such a fine
group of people getting ready to
introduce
the next president of the united states
i like many of you and your families
came here
looking for better opportunities
i was lucky to graduate college get
married
and raise our beautiful son michael
michael is now 13 years old
fighting a pre-existing condition called
brittle bones disease
it is thanks to the obama biden
administration
and their work to pass the affordable
care act
that my son can't be denied medical care
because of
his pre-existing condition
i vote democrats because they fight for
people like my son
and their right to quality affordable
healthcare the last few months have been
have not been easy either we all know
how the coronavirus has
hurt workers here in las vegas before
this pandemic
i work five different jobs as a banquet
server
all five of those jobs are offline now
it's clear to me that donald trump has
failed to do what
is necessary to protect americans from
the health and economic impact of this
virus
i am lucky but i still have a job and
medical insurance for my family
but what about those who aren't so lucky
what happens to them who is looking out
for them
and their families that's why
we need joe biden someone who liked
us grew in a working-class community
not on park avenue joe
cares about us he'll fight for us
yes times are tough but like joe biden
one word describes the spirit of nevada
resilience with joe biden as our next
president
we are going to move past the darkness
of the last four years
on to a brighter future
24 days from now nevada
we have a chance to answer this nation's
call for compassion
for faith for resiliency
it is my honor to introduce to you
the next president of the united states
joe biden
hello hello hello
hello
thank you thank you thank you thank you
hello las vegas
governor sisterlock senator rose
representative titus
and my good friend congressman
well actually he's a great friend but we
also have congressman lee in congress of
horsford
and thank you for the passport into the
district
and i want to thank the principal of
this great school ryan
cordia here at south east
career technical academy for hosting
this and just when he needed today
you know i i know you wish uh your
students could be here
uh but i uh i think that uh we're gonna
all look forward to that day
soon i wanna thank you all and your
staff
for doing all you've done in this
challenging time
and alejandro thank you for the
introduction
and you and all the people who chose and
parents chose to come to the united
states
are the reason why we are the nation we
are thank you thank you thank you
look i know times are tough
especially for folks working in
hospitality before the pandemic and
recession
you in your case alejandra i still had
to work two jobs
now it's one you're just trying to do
right by your family
just like so many people across the
country i just leave
left east las vegas community center
with assemblyman edgar flores
son of mexican immigrants i got to talk
to his dad he got to swear at his dad
as a united states citizen last week
he became a lawyer to fight for the
rights of immigrants
he made sure that he met with the i met
with a group of latino leaders
who fight for respect and dignity that
we're all entitled to
no matter who we are or where we're from
yesterday i was with kamal harris in
arizona after her outstanding debate
performance
i couldn't be prouder of running
alongside her she's always
looking out for the people for you you
know
we we took a tour through phoenix we met
with the workers and small business
owners and tribal leaders
remember cindy mccain john mccain's wife
a widow
and a dear friend of an american hero
john mccain we also
saw the resilience and the goodness and
decency of the american people
they're not looking for a handout they
just want a fair shot
my dad used to have an expression when
he lost his job
up in scranton when i was in grade
school my dad would say
and i we had to move in with my
grandparents when he went down
south from scranton to wilmington
delaware looking for a job
and he used to always say that you know
the fact is joey i'm not looking for a
government to solve my problems but i
hope in hell i can at least understand
my problems
he finally got a job we could afford to
buy a small home
he worked hard to build a decent
middle-class life
it wasn't easy for him but he had an
expression
as i said a job joey is about a lot more
than a paycheck it's about your dignity
it's about respect it's about your place
in the community
just being able to look your kid in the
eye and say honey it's going to be okay
you deserve a president who understands
what you're going through
who sees you where you are and where you
want to be
the last thing you need is a president
who ignores you
looks down upon you who just doesn't
understand who in god's name we are
that's president trump his reckless
personal conduct since his diagnosis
to the stabilizing effect it's having on
our government is unconscionable
he didn't take the necessary precautions
to protect himself
or others and the longer donald trump is
president
the more reckless he gets how can we
trust him to protect this country
governor you've seen how he picks fights
with states
and piss them against one another look
what's happened
more than 210 000 americans are dead
four hundred and twenty thousand have
been hospitalized
we lose anywhere from seven hundred to a
thousand people
every single day in america worse than
any country in the world
more than 7.5 million americans have
been infected and we're still
counting and here in nevada have been
more than 82 000 cases in total
more than 1 600 deaths
80 percent of those deaths have been
seniors over 60 years of age
black latino asian americans and native
american communities
are especially hit hard nationally
the affection rate among latinos is
almost
three times higher than that of white
non-latinos and the death rate as well
is three
times higher more than forty thousand
latinos
have died from covert nineteen my heart
goes out to all those families
we got up this morning there was an
empty chair
around the kitchen table i'll go to
dinner tonight
and the person that should be there is
gone
you know they've lost part of their soul
i lost part of their life
it's all about family with you and i
it's all about family
losing family is a devastating thing
we can do so much better my heart goes
out to everyone struggling
with the economic crisis caused by the
neglect the simple neglect of this
president
nearly 11 million jobs lost since the
beginning of this crisis
and they still haven't come back
including 136 000 jobs here in nevada
layoffs have turned to permanent layoffs
record growth last month and the number
of americans facing long-term
unemployment
and the problem with long-term
unemployment once you get beyond a
certain point history shows us
that they never get a job again
all told there are now 30 million
workers
with their lost hours lost paychecks
or lost their jobs entirely roughly 700
000 people have dropped out of the labor
force
last month and the vast majority were
women
we're still down 647
000 manufacturing jobs nationwide
since the crisis has started and our
balance of payment steps are going up
and here in nevada the unemployment rate
is 13.2 percent
the highest in the nation because of
president trump's negligence
the hospitality industry has been
particularly hard
the culinary union has recently said
publicly that
50 of their members are still out of
work
tourism in june was down 70 percent
from a year ago the result
president trump will be the first
president in modern history since hoover
to leave office with fewer jobs
than he had when he came into office
here in nevada after seeing over 200
000 jobs created in the last seven years
of the biden obama biden administration
nevada has actually seen jobs go down
under the trump presidency he's leaving
us what he calls
he says it's a v-shaped recession it's a
k-shaped recession
where those at the top keep going up
and the middle class and everyone else
keeps going down
getting worse it means essential workers
who sacrifice to keep us going through
this pandemic
are being left behind by the most
unequal recovery
in modern history you get this
the top 100 billionaires
in america have done pretty well just in
the pandemic
the top 100 billionaires have made an
additional
300 billion dollars
top 100 but you get
the bottom half of that k and it's a
downward slide
you'll have to figure out how you're
going to pay your bills
put food on the table so much food
insecurity in america in this state
how to balance doing your job with being
a teacher for your kids because because
of the negligence of the president they
can't go back to school because they
haven't provided the wherewithal
for schools to open you're asked to risk
your neck
because you can't work from home or the
risk of covering
are kept outside that's because you're a
police officer
a firefighter a nurse or you work on an
assembly line
in customer service or a checkout
counter
or here in vegas and hospitality if
you're a housekeeper
a casino worker built
the ones who built this very stage
governor sisalak your members of
congress are doing everything they
possibly can
to help turn things around governor
you've been focused and responsible you
followed science
put public health and safety first you
made tough calls that saved lives
working around the clock so we can
reopen schools in the economy safely
your members of congress have done the
same
and the house passed what they call the
heroes act
months ago would have provided billions
of dollars to help states keep
first responders on the job the safety
measures needed
the ppp needed to open our schools and
businesses
but donald trump and mitch mcconnell
republican leader did nothing to move
the legislation
nothing in june nothing in july
nothing in august nothing in september
things getting worse and worse and worse
and as people struggled and suffered
what do they focus on
if this wasn't so serious you think i'm
making it up what they focused on
is more tax cuts for the wealthy not a
joke
the proposal is another 30 billion
dollar tax cut
for millionaires and billionaires
cuts in funding cutting the means by
which we fund the social security system
leading the actuary of social security
to say if they do it
by 2023 mid-2023 there'll be no money
for social security and a relentless
effort
to eliminate as alejandro said the
affordable care act
which provides health care coverage for
22 million people
won over 100 million with pre-existing
conditions
this is going on at the same time he's
already cost
10 million people their health insurance
because their companies have gone
bankrupt
it's unconscionable instead of focusing
on our needs your needs
he's trying to make take your health
care away he's literally before the
supreme court as i speak
to strike down the entire affordable
care act
take away that health care for 20
million americans
that's 282 000 nevadans
take away federal protections for
pre-existing conditions
1.2 million nevadans
and complications from covet like lung
scarring and heart damage
could well become the next pre-existing
condition
striking down the affordable care act
would toss out the rule that allows our
children
to be covered on their parents insurance
policy till age 26.
take us backward when insurance
companies could change charge a woman
more for health care than a man for the
same procedure
just because she's a woman take away
medicare benefits for seniors
increase their drug protection their
drug prescription costs
and just as he vowed to co-terminate
as i said earlier the funding for social
security
the idea that in just a few years
could put at risk 410
000 nevada's rely on a dignified
retirement
because of social security
and all this during all this not
once did president trump
call a high-level meeting of democrats
and republicans to the white house
to resolve these issues i've served with
a lot of presidents
never no matter how good or bad you
thought they were do they fail
to try to bring parties together in the
white house
to reach a settlement you know why
he spent so much time hiding in the
bunker in the white house
or on the bunker of his golf course
playing
hundreds of rounds of golf and then this
tuesday
what'd he do he said end of discussions
he wasn't even starting
no more negotiations no more
negotiations
and now today he says well i'm back
one thing for sure donald trump shows
no urgency to deliver hard-working
americans
like the family i grew up in like all of
you
but they need now desperately
for exactly two months since the
emergency small
business program your congress people
voted for
has closed down two months
of small business owners in nevada and
across the country
waiting hoping for just a little extra
help to be able to stay open
now we have more than 400 000 small
businesses have been permanently closed
by the way the largest employers in
america are small businesses
millions more are struggling to hang on
how many more will go under how many
more dreams will be extinguished
because of the selfishness of this
president the republican leaders in
congress make no mistake
if you're out of work if your business
is closed
if your child's school will shut down if
you're facing eviction
as millions are over 20 million
americans worry about whether they're
going to be able to pay their mortgage
next month
none of that seems to matter to donald
trump
you're a firefighter police officer who
depends on state and local budgets
he's turned his back on you as well
because they've got to balance their
budgets
they're being laid off all over america
when brock and i were elected
we inherited the worst recession short
of the great depression in history
he put me in charge of what's called the
recovery act
800 billion dollars we passed and needed
to get out
into the economy within 18 months to
prevent a depression
we did it with less than two-tenths of
percent of waste or fraud
and i was able to see to it to the
states in order to keep moving
keep teachers firefighters first
responders
all employed i was able to get 140
billion dollars in aid out to the states
right here in clark county i was able to
bring
two 1.2 billion dollars
to keep your economy going
we have that ability now
the house has already passed a similar
piece of legislation
and we started the longest sustained
recovery in american history
but you know what mitch mcconnell said
about helping the states
i'm not making this up he said let them
go bankrupt
let them go bankrupt
what and the hell is he talking about
folks we're so much better than this
we can turn this crisis into progress
we can contain this virus to fully
reopen our economy
we make up four percent of the world's
population
and we have 20 percent of the world's
deaths
if we just follow the science expand
testing and tracing
social disease washing our hands
implementing nationwide mass mandates
don't politicize the race for a vaccine
mr president
just have a plan for a safe and
equitable distribution
on the economy bring the congress back
together to pass
real relief to help people who've lost
their unemployment
checks as well and then implement a
comprehensive agenda
i have laid out to make bold investments
so we can build back better
you know he keeps talking about the
republicans some republicans keep
a lot of them are acknowledging and
supporting me but a lot of them also are
talking about
well biden's going to spend all this
money well guess what
the independent analysis put out by
moody's on
a wall street firm did a detailed
analysis of my recovery plan and the
president's
here's what they said it's off of wall
street
that my plan will create 18.6 million
jobs in four years
seven million more jobs than the
president's plan
and one trillion dollars more in
economic growth than the president's
plan
democrats know how to get things done
here's how my plan works it's not going
to raise a penny in tax for anyone
making less than
400 000 a year
not a penny
and how i'm going to pay for all this
i'm going to ask
the big corporations and the wealthy to
start paying their fair share
you realize that the fortune 500
companies
92 of them making billions of dollars
don't pay a single
penny in taxes it's wrong
donald trump paying 720 dollars in taxes
come on the money we raise
by eliminating the 1.3 trillion of his 2
trillion
tax cut that affects the super wealthy
and corporations we're going to invest
in working people
we're going to grow the middle class to
make sure everyone's included on the
deal
the kinds of investment that will
stimulate the economy
including industries like tourism and
hospitality
to get back to full employment fast and
help build back better than before
it means the analysis shows creating
millions of good
paying union jobs
manufacturing and technology
making sure our future is made in
america
when we the president in the white house
gives out 600 billion dollars in
contracts per year
well guess what when i'm president
it's going to go to no outfit that
doesn't
make it in america the whole thing and
sell it in america
i mean it in infrastructure building
roads bridges highways ports airports
and clean energy upgrading four million
buildings and weatherizing two million
homes creating at least at least a
million
good paying jobs in the process making
the climate safer saving
hundreds of millions of barrels of oil
we'll deal with climate change by
creating millions of union jobs
that build the climate resilience of our
cities and our towns fighting back
stronger
more frequent wildfires feeding heat
waves droughts hurricanes and floods
by the way did you hear what the
president said about hurricanes
this summer he was told about how
they're coming across the warm water in
the in atlantic
and if they get to the the closer they
get to the shore the more
worse they get nobody said hello rondo
alejandro
he said maybe we should drop an atomic
weapon on them
and blow them up as we say in my
religion bless me father for i have
sinned what's going on here
under my plan small business come out
the other side of this crisis with
access to capital
and the ability to deal with their debts
we're going to get 50 billion dollars in
new capital
especially for minority-owned businesses
and small businesses
we're going to make another 100 billion
dollars in low-interest loans available
to these businesses
creating jobs increasing economic growth
and increasing incomes a fifteen million
dollar
fifteen 15 minimum wage
i'm dreaming here but a 15
minimum wage for our essential workers
we're not just going to praise you
we're going to pay you for the good wage
ensure you have strong benefits we'll
ease the burden of the major costs in
your life
we'll build the affordable care act
writing new health insurance options
not-for-profit public options which give
private insurers a real competitor
we're going to increase subsidies for
premiums and lower your costs
increase plans that will lower
deductibles and lower out-of-pocket
expenses
and we're going to take on the
pharmaceutical industry
with a plan that will slash cost the
prescription drugs by
50 the reason i'm not going to more
detail you about here a long time let's
give me one example
if in fact medicare
is able to negotiate for all the drugs
they buy
and say you're not going to be able to
sell them to them unless you pay the
price words they're
suggesting that would drop by 60 percent
the cost the cost of drugs
we'll also make high quality child care
available accessible
we'll work with the states to ensure
that every three four
year old will get access to free high
quality
preschool not not not
daycare we're going to make sure
low middle income families never have to
spend more than seven percent of their
income
to care for young children because if we
truly want to reward
work in this country we have to ease the
financial burdens and create
the care for families that are caring
for raising a child
and an aging loved one look and the
professional caregivers out there
home health care workers child care
workers we're offered more often women
women of color immigrants are too often
underpaid under seen and undervalued
that's why my build back better plan
will elevate the compensation benefits
and dignity of
caring caregiving workers and early
childhood educators
we're also going to triple the funding
for title 1 schools like the one behind
me here
which serve high number of children from
low income families
we're going to make four years of public
college and universities
tuition free for any family that makes
less than 125
000 a year
we're going to make community college
and job training programs free for all
hard-working
americans that qualify and if you're
buying your first home
we're going to provide a 15 000 tax
credit to help you
get there
we're going to protect social security
and increase benefits for millions of
seniors look
i'm not going to lay it out but go to
joebiden.com
go to moody's look it up we pay for all
this and we grow the economy at the same
time
the fact is president united states can
only see the world from park avenue
he thinks wall street built this country
and ceos
i see the world from where i grew up in
scranton pennsylvania and claymont
communities like some that you live in i
know the middle class working people
built this country
the measure of economic success is by
what our families are
talking about around the kitchen table
are you able to look your kid in the eye
and say honey it's going to be okay
how many times do you know somebody this
morning had to say i know look i know
those
those tires are bald but you got to ride
on them for another 20 000 miles we just
don't have the money
we just can't do it now who's going to
tell her
she can't go back to school because we
can't continue to borrow the money to
keep her in that community college
there's a discussion that took place
around my table
and i'm sure yours as well but we're
going to get anything done
we got to come together i made a speech
i worked really really hard on and
thought
really hard about before i made it in
gettysburg pennsylvania on the
battlefield
last week
i said at that time that we're facing a
crisis
not unlike we did after gettysburg
i said there that i'm running as a proud
democrat but i'm going to govern
as an american president
i'm going to work as hard for those who
don't support
me as those who do because after all
this country has been through
after all that america has accomplished
after
all the years we've stood as a beacon of
light to the world
we cannot be we cannot be
that here and now in 2020
we allow the government the government
of the people
by the people and for the people to
perish from this earth
folks we have it in our hands
and i mean this on the bottom we have it
in our hands the ultimate power
what's the ultimate power in the
democracy the power to vote
here in nevada the best thing you can do
is vote early and return your ballot
quickly
ballots here in clark county were mailed
two days ago on wednesday
you can return your ballot by mail you
can drop it off at a drop box
or vote in person during the early vote
or on election day but just make a plan
seriously go to iwillvote.com
nv make a plan
don't risk any delays return that mail
on ballot as soon as you can
make sure your voice is heard
we can be better than what we've seen
we can be what we are at our best
the united states of america
i'm confident we can bring democrats and
republicans together again
with him gone folks
conclude by saying there has never
ever ever been anything the united
states but
unable to accomplish when we've done it
together
never never never so folks
let's stand up and vote and take back
this country now thank you thank you
thank you
thank you appreciate it
foreign
thank you
yes
oh